Hello, and welcome to the 2013 Project for Awesome.
Waaaaaa..!
Hank, are you there or is it just Bobble John?
It's just Bobble John. My head came off!
Oh no!
I'm okay, I'm okay.
I'm just gonna let this happen.
Continue what you were saying, please.
Let me put this hat on.
Ladies and gentlemen, my insane brother.
Michael is editing you scooping the brains out of a squirrel right now.
It is the most disgusting video we have ever done!
The squirrel needed to see a dentist real bad.
I blame Squirrel-bama.
Oh, that's the sweetest wrestling I've ever seen.
I am bigger than you.
I know! Just let me take control!
Am I gonna hula for you? Good...good question!
Here's a good answer: no.
Put sharpies in my nose.
You get to work every morning at 6 o' clock?
I do!
Do you want to come work for me because you could literally sleep in three extra hours every day.
Yes.
Do you see it?
I'm having a religious moment.
I think his name is Jeff the Buttdog.
Aghshjgsguaghjahagashuiah!
I'm in a dark wall, I can't go...and there is nowhere to...
I don't like it!
This has been an interesting couple of minutes!
I'm concerned that the patriarchy might not even survive to the end of the Project for Awesome.
Just kidding! Just kidding, it's deeply entrenched.
We're adding a new perk right now, and I'm wearing it.
Well first of all, he's a smaller man than I am.
This is...not what it looks like on Alex.
The number of people watching this just sharply decreased, so... I don't know how to take that.
How do you make a cat look like Benedict Cumberbatch?
Well, blue scarf, right?
I CAME IN LIKE A WRECKING BALL
Make that clearer, not more confusing. Like, the quark model clears things up, amazingly.
No!
Oh...
Just so that I can sit there and have the authentic experience of properly eating salami.
This is my first ever spoken word piece.
It's called "Bullies."
Why are you doing pelvic thrusts?
Because you told me to tap dance!
My hair is everything!
How did you so precisely get your eyes?
I've been practicing!
It will look like this except it won't already be on cardboard.
It will just be, y'know, just a poster that you can roll and unroll, but it'll look like this.
What is my Sharpie face removal plan?
Why didn't I think about this before I started to cover my face in Sharpie?
Shorty had them apple bottom jeans and boots with the fur. The whole club was a-lookin' at her!
Three, two, one.
Zoom in, zoom in!
Now we're looking at my blood move.
We just raised $525,000!
This is my favorite time of year to be a Nerdfighter,
and it's when I'm proudest of the Nerdfighter community because I get to see the work that we do together.
I know that it's hard to take me seriously when I'm covered, still slightly covered, in Sharpie.
I feel you, bro.
And thanks for getting me into this mess.
The Project for Awesome Indiegogo page is open for another 36-ish hours.
You can still get all kinds of amazing things there!
My Christmas album, John's sneak peek of the new thing that he's writing,
Project for Awesome t-shirts, posters, commemorative coins, men and women of YouTube charity calendars,
Michael Aranda's actual headshots from when he was 15 years old, and my fake headshot from when I was 8.
Also, yes, The Fault in Our Stars has a movie poster, and this is the only way that you could get it.
So, if you want to get that, it's only 25 bucks.
And it's all for charity! It's a donation!
All I gotta say is thank you.
Thank you to everybody who commented, who watched the livestream, who made a video, who donated money.
Thanks to everybody who came and joined us on the live show and who participated,
and the men and women of YouTube charity calendars.
And of course, thanks to our amazing volunteer support staff,
who stayed up all hours of the day and night with us.
Thanks to Michael Aranda, who designed the poster and the t-shirt.
Thanks to Karen Kavett, who designed the calendar and the website.
And thanks to our web developer, Sam Rudge, and Fastly, our hosting service who did it for free.
This really is one of my favorite parts of my life,
so thank you all for being so great.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.